morning everyone welcome to Carnegie
Mellon so we're really looking forward
to this visit by Mark Zuckerberg as you
know he's this will be his first ever
university tour and he's visiting three
places yesterday he was at MIT and
Harvard and today he's coming here we're
really pleased that he chose here to
come so Facebook as you know is going
great guns and they really like our
students they've recruited a fair number
we have about 57 of our alumni are not
working at Facebook and we've had quite
a few student interns there as well our
students sort of learn both the basic
principles and the practice so when they
show up on the job they're ready to get
going and yet they also have the sort of
deep understanding that continues them
through their whole careers
hey it were blue return kipper that's
gone who's bothering all right
[Music]
well we have a lot of Carnegie Mellon
alums at Facebook and a lot of them are
actually some of our best engineers so
when we decided to organize this trip to
go see a few colleges Carnegie Mellon
was at the top of the list so that's
what we're here it's my first time out
here I'm excited to be here Facebook and
well Facebook looks for really
entrepreneurial folks right people who
are trying to have a big impact on the
world and who have the ability to look
at any of a hundred different problems
at once and see okay this is the one
that we really need to solve right
because Facebook we serve a lot of users
and customers are more than 800 million
people around the world but the
organization is actually really small
we just passed I think 700 engineers
right so each engineer at Facebook
serves more than a million users
themselves you can think about it that
way so we need people who really have
this desire to have a huge impact on the
world and that's really the biggest
thing that we look for that then
obviously really good technical skills
oh I mean we have a whole process of the
company it's we really value teamwork as
well so it's really important to us that
people who are coming through have an
opportunity to talk to a variety of
folks we test them both on technical
skills and on teamwork ability and and
kind of how they fit with the values of
Facebook wanting to have an impact
wanting to help people connect things
like that and then everyone who joins
the company goes through the short
bootcamp period where they basically go
for six weeks and learn all the
different parts of the code so it's a
really unique thing that we do to get
people ramped up on our code or uses
some of the CMU engineers your
investment engineers can you tell us why
um I don't know why they're just they're
really smart and they have a really good
work ethic all right I think we're good
thank you guys